this dude what did you used to do for a
living uh you saw on a taxi company
restaurant takeaways and it was a big
taxi company
and in 2016 when we met he had a massive
taxi company but what happened to the
taxi company it went downhill it went
downhill and went into liquidation went
to liquidation so you decided to get to
property instead so you came on some of
my training programs what happened uh
life exploded
things changed um
i trained in deal sourcing and i set up
a new company called action invest and
also right now you know he's living a
good life you just you just bought your
dream motorhome
yeah 60 000 pound motorhome to go on
holidays renting out as well but so so
you're buying properties yourself but
you're also buying properties packaging
them and selling them to investors
how much do you charge for that service
three to five thousand pounds and how
many of those deals are you doing uh on
average per month um four a month one a
week at the moment okay you do the math
three to five grand once a week boom
property is the way forward folks